well today kicks off black restaurant
week in las vegas the goal
is to promote the flavors of
african-american african and caribbean
cuisine
kate houston spoke with the owner of an
egyptian restaurant about how this event
helps give exposure to local eateries
here at potts they specialize in vegan
egyptian street food and by
participating in black restaurant week
they hope to introduce new flavors to
people across the valley
bringing uniqueness through food
it was always my my way
to bring my character out and to talk to
people through my food
iman hagag opened pot's egyptian
restaurant on rainbow in okie three
years ago
over the next week hagag will be
showcasing the fresh flavors of egyptian
food
which has greek french middle eastern
and indian influences
reaching a bigger audience and bigger
base for them to try it's it's it's a
way to reach out to more people
and learning about them learning about
us that community focus is one of the
main goals for black restaurant week
partner fallon farrell
the event started six years ago to
promote black owned restaurants across
the nation
and highlight the systemic barriers
facing business owners
this is the first year it's in las vegas
with a focus on helping businesses
recover from the pandemic
businesses in our community don't have
the cash flow
to do marketing campaigns so when the
door when the
finances start to tighten they can't go
and say okay well let me go
do this huge marketing campaign to
create more awareness
and so that's that's the problem that
we're solving potts will join many other
restaurants throughout the next week in
highlighting their most popular dishes
i think it's a really great thing to
reach out to different communities from
all over
and for vegas to participate in black
restaurant week i think it's a step
ahead kate houston
8 news now wow that food looked great
other restaurants that are going to be
participating include simply pure soul
food grits cafe
big chicken shack a whole lot more black
restaurant week by the way runs through
next sunday march 21st